[Music]
so one of the things that I've been
trying to figure out and with a bunch of
our allies some of that I've had on my
show I've been saying I'm finding it a
lot easier right now to build bridges
with people that are thought of as more
traditionally on the right because at
least it's rooted in the individual
which is obviously a big part of
everything you're talking about yeah
do you see room to build anything left
with what is the the modern left for the
most part for so for example they'll
they'll prop up someone like Linda
Sarsour and basically not ever offer you
a platform or even for me I only get
invited to colleges from the Young
Republicans and the libertarians and the
freedom yeah this and that and I think
it's probably very similar to you I
think that your observation that people
who identify as conservative in this
country and ironically liberal in Europe
right right which is another thing which
we have a show on the Internet and all
the 14th April crazy yeah yeah so people
who identify as conservative in this
country in the United States of America
they find it so much easier to see you
know what is unfree about so many of
these non-western cultures I find it so
much easier to talk to Tucker Carlson on
Fox News about female genital mutilation
and I really appreciate his you know the
horrified look on his show on his face
and the fact that he thinks this is a
practice he doesn't care where it's
justified in the name of culture or
religion or there it needs to stop and
he is going to use his influence and his
position to make that point and then I
look at the New York Times one of these
New York Times editors who says you know
what maybe we should in order for these
cultures to come or to to lessen to to
narrow the gap between this couch
and that culture maybe we need to stop
calling mutilation and call it a cut or
whatever and that I don't I mean it is
literal you're not making this up I'm
not okay that it was written yeah her
name is escaping me yeah but when I when
I look at that kind of reasoning that
kind of logic and I look here as a free
woman she calls herself a liberal she is
with probably the most powerful
newspaper in the United States of
America as all this influence why on
earth is she making this terrible
trade-off and the trade-off is this is
it the individual who's actually going
through the mutilation or potentially
may go through the mutilation and that
individual is a child four five six
years old seven years old sometimes
younger some cultures they start at
infancy versus some vague abstract
notion called culture or some kind of
group so people will come and present
themselves grownups and say well if you
call it mutilation then I'm offended to
my core yeah so this is what Bill Maher
describes as the soft bigotry of low
expectations yeah right like we have to
change all the words and never say or
things exactly are yeah this could
inflame the see that goes to you you
know conservatives versus liberals and
it becomes so much easier for people
like me for people who come from the
countries where this these terrible
things take place in it is justified in
the name of culture and religion and a
combination of the two that we think
yeah conservatives are our friends yeah
because you know they may have a very
passionate position on closing borders
and getting illegals out and all of
these things but when it comes to honor
killings when it comes to female genital
mutilation when it comes to you know if
you are a gay Muslim man just imagine
what you're going through when it comes
to all this Muslim opposites we find
that people conservatives in this
country make it so much easier know
yeah I spoke at University of Arizona a
couple weeks ago and I was saying hi to
some of the kids after and a kid came up
to me and I could see he was really
nervous and he was shaking a little bit
and he said to me that watching my show
has helped him you know think about some
things and they told me he said I've
never told him on this but I'm ex-muslim
yeah and then he said to me and
something else I'm also like you yes man
he was gay and he just he couldn't
really say it and I didn't I didn't even
know what to do and he was starting to
cry and I just had to hug him and yeah I
was kind of tearing up yeah and I
thought this is the ultimate irony here
yeah Here I am with the I forget it was
a young Republicans or whatever group it
was yeah and here is where he had to
come for refuge and yet they'll be
slammed as the people who are racists
and bigots and homophobes in oh yes but
ironically again in 2017 it's the
conservatives who take very clear
positions on practical Islam on
anti-semitism on the killing of gays
some of them may be against gay marriage
but here we have a religion that says
gays should be killed
you never come out of the closet because
you risk getting killed by your own
family so in that sense I think it's it
there is a big shameful smear on the
people who describe themselves as
liberals and who make excuses for these
cultures these low expectations in the
faces of bigotry of low expectations
yeah so I'll put you on the spot here if
if more left-wing outlets and I said to
you I said I get the same thing I only
get invited when I get TV things it's
only from Fox people say why are you why
are you go on MSNBC interviews I can't
bust down their door so but if you got
more invites from the things that are
thought of as liberal or less or import
invited to schools or wherever else you
would do that correct right well I would
do that I have I have a relationship
with CNN I've been on the on their show
many times when you know something
happens I have I hide for The Daily
Beast once in a while it's not they're
not monolithic and within every
organization there are individuals you
know who just you know computer common
sense
yeah say these things are inhuman these
are violations of our human rights and
these things should stop but very often
I also hear I can't say this I can't do
this because the rest of the
organization doesn't want it and they
prioritize other subjects or they let
the Muslim Brotherhood front groups take
the stage and and sedate them basically
into saying that Islam is a religion of
peace and none of these things has to do
with Islam and Muslims in America are
victims of Islamophobia and this is then
yeah I mean I can see as you're saying
it's so ridiculous to you that you're
sort of laughing as you're saying it so
like when you say that you're talking
about basically a group like care every
time something happens yeah
within 10 seconds yeah I'm probably
giving it an extra nine seconds yeah
there immediately I'm talking about
Islamophobia as opposed to the victims
yeah or the certainly not the ideology
or the rest of it yeah you're saying
that this this is part of Dawa this is
part of a lot of Dawa because what they
have seen is this weakness in the West
is a colleague of mine at Hoover shall
be still whom I really respect and
admire he calls it white guilt and this
white guilt was bad before there were
any Muslims in the United States of
America but organizations like the
Council of American Islamic relations
day series and they exploded and
sometimes they manufacture these you
know they talk about a backlash no
backlash ever happens and then they
start manufacturing stories so all I
mean you look at the FBI makes these
reports on hate crimes and you see that
again in the United States of America
unfortunately the num the largest number
of recorded hate crimes is against Jews
there is a little bit against Muslims
and then even from of that ends up being
your manna function yes and when care
uses cases like those they don't tell
the public or but this case has been
debunked they simply keep using it and
the whole point is they see that people
feel guilty and it's a way of shutting
people up
it's a way of stopping them from
questioning and then what you get is
that people start talking about instead
of talking about it openly in open
platform you see you hear people talk
about it you know behind closed doors
and on birthdays scenes where you can't
really have a proper debate from both
sides right and then it's unhealthy
well it's unhealthy but then the irony
is that then you know a terrorist attack
happened they immediately do that and
then the only time that these networks
put some of the reformers or the
ex-muslim so maje it or you or whoever
else they only put them on right after
when the when the feelings are still
overall yeah any we're doing this
hopefully nothing happened while we're
doing this and we'll put it out and
it'll be for people to learn yeah but
but the media now at least cable news is
so reactive yeah that you have these
competing things that are that make no
sense together you have the reaction of
it's Islamophobia as as I think you said
in one of the things the bodies were
still warm you know and then and then or
you have the reaction of they only put
you on while it's happening and it's
still raw so it's like a competing
forces or they frame a story in such a
way that all you know Major Nidal Malik
Hasan attack was workplace violence
Orlando was just another gay hating man
and it has nothing to do with what are
you saying right to do you know and had
he been Christian of course they would
have said it could have found the most
light connection to Christianity yeah
the left would have went bananas with
this and they would've said you see the
Westboro Baptist Church and the
Christians are doing this yeah but they
and that's what's causing the backlash
because they're going so out of there
they're bending over backwards
yeah and they starting to look
ridiculous there is no backlash you see
right we live in a country of about
three hundred three million three three
million over millionaire three hundred
million three hundred twenty five
million people and if you look at again
these FBI effects it's really minimal
you don't see a backlash you see the
opposite you see people Americans saying
you're I'm going to protect my Muslim
Europe right you see rabbis and
Christian priests and the leadership
going out and
organizing more interfaith Muslims being
welcome everywhere you don't see a
battle ash they've been saying this in
Europe they've been saying it is no
battle at right we see the only he'll
write something neat and then half of
them turn out to be fake yeah yeah and
by the way that happens on all sides
that whole thing about the JCC is the
Jewish Community Center is being called
we turned out to be an Israeli those
Jewish Israeli so so again you can see
things bad wherever they were oh yeah
but when something like that happens
within the Jewish community in Jewish
communities because there are several
Jewish communities they get incensed no
and they stop it and they come out and
say yes this is one of us this guy is
one of us and for whatever reason he is
doing it he needs to be stopped but when
you look at the Muslim leadership have
you seen anyone come out among you know
the organized Muslim groups to say let's
stop this now
this whole bogus Islamophobia charge
let's stop it let's do away with it yeah
you don't see that would you see a
people like us or no money and the other
Muslim performers who are saying we
don't feel the backlash as Muslims in
fact we're more scared of these
organized Islamists then we are about
some kind of extreme right-wing backlash
that never happens right okay so I want
to before we finish I want to talk a
little bit at the end about your
foundation and what you're doing because
I think you're you're building some new
things now that I think are important
and a network to stop a network I think
is loosely what you said before which
yeah that's what we need but I do want
to spend a couple minutes talking about
female genital mutilation because we've
mentioned it I read your piece about it
and you describe the five types and it's
horrific and the only reason I want to
talk about it is because it was because
reading it and even the way you wrote it
I think after the third type yeah you
said this is getting hard to read it was
hard to read from the beginning so it's
like that effect and really I really was
having trouble reading I mean yeah so
this really awful so we can go through
all of them if you want but we don't
have to but can you just for a couple
minutes just lay out what's going on
there because people are now hearing it
and you're right when the New York
transmen says what it's cutting yeah and
you know last night you described oh
yeah they're in some academics say this
has been going on for a long time it
must have some kind of value and that we
as Westerners don't
understand so we should just let it be
yeah well so we'll link to the article
down below so people can read it but if
you want to just lay out a little bit of
it well the first thing I want to point
out is this is being done to children
it's being done to girls little girls
vulnerable by people they trust their
parents their extended family
grandmothers aren't a lot of women are
involved in keeping these tractors in
place they have their reasons for doing
it they say it's religious it's to give
the girl the opportunity for a husband
in the future whatever so this poor
little girl is really not consulted at
any moment but whether she wants it or
not is harmful and in some cases it's so
harmful and debilitating it leads to
paralysis it leads to death
children bleed to death it leads I can't
even begin to talk about the
psychological effects of once you
realize that a part of you has to go
because it's filthy and so you have to
realize that it's happening to children
yes it does happen outside of the United
States and now we are seeing those
cultures come here and carry on the
practice you know we have laws here that
purport to protect our children and what
you're doing by accepting this practice
or turning a blind eye to it is that you
are saying the United States laws that
protect all girls and women do not
protect these few Gulf from Egypt from
Sudan whose parents are from Egypt and
Sudan and Saudi Arabia and India or
Pakistan any of these countries where
it's commonplace to cut the genitals of
girls to mutilate and to close them the
law does not protect them so you're
quite literally saying we have laws
except for the people who need those
laws the most I mean it's the height of
absurdity it's the height of absurdity
again you go back to the bigotry this is
it stunning everything if you are not a
faces and you really mean it
then you should open up these laws to
little bells from these cultures we
first marriages with honor killings it's
the same thing if you believe that the
law should protects all women to own
their own bodies and to make their own
choices then the same laws should
protect these girls the girls who come
to the AHA Foundation at the age of 16
17 I'm being forced to marry if I
disagree I'm going to be killed by my
father we can't get law enforcement to
help out we give we you know when we
teach we train we've created training
manuals we talk to service providers and
all that but one thing that I really
think needs to become and this is our
aspiration the aspiration of the AHA
foundation is to make every American
aware of the fact that these practices
child marriage forced marriage female
genital mutilation on all violence and
honor killings are happening right here
and these vulnerable women excluded
excluded from the laws that protects us
all yeah so then I think as a perfect
ending so your foundation you've changed
around a few things you guys are growing
I know you're doing a partnership with
basil um for people that want to get
involved because I do think we're
getting some wins here this type of
stuff is starting to resonate yeah how
can they get well vib I mean of course
people can give money and help get
voices out and help find some people
that are in closed societies and things
like that yeah but what else can people
do volunteer work because if what you
know if you understand what the problem
is and you have the time you can help us
take that awareness volunteer your time
if you're good with social media or
other ways of reaching as many people as
possible please help us out if you are a
teacher if you are a policeman if you
are any other service provider somewhere
in the country and you're confronted
with any of these practices please let
us know yeah we are an activist group
and again we want to shine the light on
these terrible practices against women
but we also want to work with all other
groups that are targeted by Sharia we
want to work with the gay community we
want to work with the Jewish communities
we want to work with the Christian
communities nobody
really in the united very few people
very few groups talk about what is done
to Christians in the Middle East
these blasphemy laws etc and how this
whole thing is finding its way into
traditionally Christian country yeah I
mean there's almost no Christians left
in the Middle East yeah they've been
eradicated and even the ones that are
left and it's not just impetus think
about the blasphemy laws in Pakistan
think about what happens to Christians
in Malaysia and Indonesia you know none
of this is really discussed in the way
it should be it should be headline news
every single day I believe until it
stops it should we should be pressuring
our government to tie economic political
diplomatic you know to use all of these
tools as a fashion method to stop these
persecutions the mainstream media is not
reporting once in a while you see a part
here or there but it's not a campaign
doesn't look like it's being taken up
and I think we should you know make all
of this as I'm someone who's really
benefited from globalization blur I'm an
immigrant who is really grateful to have
been allowed here and the Netherlands
and to have come out of this and I think
my duty as with other successful
immigrants is to make sure that we shine
a light on these atrocities yeah well I
know it truly is about being an
individual because you've inspired
hundreds if not I'm sure thousands of
people including me that got me to get
have a little bravery to do what I do
and that's what we need so it's been a
pleasure I could talk to you all day but
I know you have a you have many more
things to do it's like thank you for
coming in and and for you guys I do want
to get involved check out ions
foundation it's a h:a Foundation org
[Music]
you
[Music]